foreign
[Music]
what shouldn't be embarrassing but is oh
I did I haven't obviously same again
always I've seen the title I haven't
read it okay cool cool getting caught
having a conversation with yourself oh
wow has that happened to you
yes yeah it actually happened
the other day bro I was in the car and
it was like you know when you're
cool I had to set myself because I had
to just make sure it wasn't with you
Okay it definitely wasn't with you but I
had to take myself because in my
imagination I just saw you in the
passenger okay but it wasn't with you
okay cool but yeah there's been an
occasion where I've been like having a
full-blown conversation with myself in
my head in the Silence of this guy it
was with you it was on the way to the JD
and coping the other day okay it was on
the way to the JD coping the other day
wow yeah bro I was we were just driving
in silence yeah yeah when we got back
from L.A we're driving in silence and
you obviously it was so minor you
wouldn't have even noticed okay but
literally it's completely silent
and then I went
from what you would have heard it would
have been me like I don't know
that's all you would have yeah and you
were like what and I was like what and
you were like Oh I thought you said
something I was like nah okay bam my
heart was racing because I was having a
full-blown conversation and you kind of
verbal and I just I got carried away
yeah yeah and you were like what I said
what you were like bro I thought you
said something and I was like no no no
no okay and you allowed cool you just
moved ones yeah yeah and I was like wow
my imagination's running wild it happens
with me but more time when I'm like
watching football that I I talk to
myself I'm talking to the screen but I'm
also talking to myself yeah having a
conversation with myself about what
United should do better yeah I know what
you agree with you I'm a green oneself
or disagree with myself whoever's
listening is listening whoever's not is
not yeah I mean I'm just in the zone I'm
just saying stuff
um when you give someone a compliment
but they didn't hear you
tough tough tough tough tough waving
back at someone who actually isn't
waving at you by the person behind you
that's happened to me so many times
double down you know you already know
it's happened to me it's happened of
course I know it's happened to Double
Down was the one of the worst things
happened to me more than that was I
can't remember where we were but I think
we're at an event because you were there
but I don't think you saw
uh for the life of me can't remember
what event it was I saw someone like it
was he was given an expression like he
wanted to help me kind of thing like
handshake blah blah blah so oh my God
handshake yeah I went for a handshake
the no everything bro didn't know who
the brother was but I thought he was
just saying wow go and love your [__]
that was my immediate assumption because
he looked in my direction and I was
thinking I did look back one of them was
little bit for you know handshake
whatever spot boom boom boom kept on
walking and looks back immediately
spotted the person behind me immediately
handshaking the person behind me I was
like damn
this wasn't meant for me I just kept it
moving I can't remember what event it
was James but you were there really you
were there I can't remember whatever it
was I would I could yeah yeah I couldn't
I couldn't vocalize what happened yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I was scream if I
saw that yeah yeah it was it was Pig
it was Peak bro yeah yeah that felt
illegal yeah
that's so illegal bro it was it was so
embarrassing Jesus it was so bad I
couldn't I couldn't sit with that that
would bring me to my knees right I'll
squat down it's so annoying bro jeez
yeah Peak he actually did that for you
as well
he just found it bro he fully charged it
fair enough I'm not gonna stop him yeah
you just charge it wow so yeah props to
my man whoever it was I can't remember
where it was but yeah
um card getting declined because you
don't have the sorry card getting the
client because you have to approve the
transaction
that never happened to me but that's
Jared oh that's happened to me that
happened to me in shoreditch in the
hotel I went to
[__] business account yeah they
thought I was doing unusual spending
they declined it three times oh I
remember you saying yeah three times bro
I had to use my personal card and she
was like you sure you don't want to use
a different card and I was like bro no
yeah I wanted to show it yeah
yeah when they ask you sure you don't
want to use a different card that's AKA
you're broke stop embarrassing everyone
fam borrow it yeah facts get out of your
CC and borrow it call whoever you need
to call
are you sure you don't want to use a
different cards
don't talk to me like that
upgrade me facts oh great how about that
yeah for two nights yeah I'm spending
what shouldn't be embarrassing but is
this one flushing twice
Shing twice
yeah bro that that that's when you know
you had a healthy damage because you've
done damaging that buff yeah in that
toilet oh that was that's crazy this
happened to me I'm just gonna say it
yeah this happened to me two days ago so
I've told you before
if you're constipated yeah you drink
pre-workout your pattern yeah yeah
I must have went to train with Lewis and
David Lloyd the other day right okay
[__] this
oh my God I went to the other day I had
a pre-workout on the way yeah and then
when I got there he's like oh there's
this new flavor of Red Bull I got you
one I was like oh no yeah so I've
already had this yeah now I'm having a
Red Bull daddy that's not good
my guts were cooking I bet and we sat
down and chatted for like 10 minutes
yeah
so as soon as he was like right you
ready to train I said family go to
toilet spring into the toilet
slam the door and I was breathing
through I slammed the door I'd like had
to like take my shirt off with one hand
you just saw the toilet before the first
push you have to yeah I know it already
before the first push you have to
regulate your breath because if the
first push is too hard your breath is
all over the place all over the place
you gotta regulate the whole thing
oh oh it's painful thinking about it
it's painful it was scary yeah so anyway
I'm there shit's down to my ankles I'm
breathing I took a deep breath
sorry
it [__] flew out of me yeah
and I was there just ah
and this one at my bro you know the
thing you get in your tool before you
nut yeah your pulsating yeah that's what
my [__] was doing bro it's Paul
saying because it didn't know if there
was more of that oh I didn't know if
there's more if it was done oh my God my
whole thing was marked bro and I was
like raw yeah anyway
these bastards have this water-saving
system
that it's like
um it's you don't touch it it's like a
wave thing wave thing fam but the way I
didn't know they set it up
that it's
for a piss flush it's put your hand
against it for a doo-doo flush it's a
wave okay I didn't know this okay so I
just literally went like that yeah and
it went trickle it trickled yeah so
that's one flush yeah and I'm like what
the [__] nothing happened and then I
inspected and then I saw this wave thing
as I say less I was waving it yeah yeah
just waving but it seems the lights
staying red it's not blinking so I'm
waving I'm waving I'm waving I'm
thinking my body's in the way yeah I'm
in this tiny little and my body's I'm
here waving waving found the things not
flushing yeah and when I say I Mark the
toilet bro I'm mug it's toilet yeah I
was like no no no no no no no no one
else this is a high-class Place yeah so
I'm waving wave is not working for them
so I grip my I I grabbed my [__] yeah
open a door and I had to like keep the
cubicle clear so I could run out run
back in and wait if I had to do it twice
before it flushed I was sweating fast I
was sweating oh my God it was the worst
experience oh my God I I absolutely
better flushing twice especially
there's no worse feeling than having to
take a Duke a serious Duke as well and
there's someone else in your yard either
a partner or a thing or you're in
someone else's yard and you feel like
either one flush ain't gonna do it or
the [__] I'm about to take is gonna take
too long that I'm gonna have to do it in
like increments
I've got to break this literally break
this [__] down
I've literally got to break this [__]
down and it's it's like yeah bro I've
had the timing taking me in there is
going to alarm her double flush is going
to alarm her 100 it's long bro 100
there's been times where a double flush
where I have to my technique is for a
double flush if someone's in the yard I
pretend to blow my nose so I flush yeah
let it all calm down yeah so she can't
hear nothing else yeah and then she can
hear me taking tissue blowing my nose
loud as possible then we're flushing
again yeah there's a reason we're
flashing again say less flipping health
I'm so embarrassing jokes
oh God realizing I'm going in the wrong
direction in public and having to turn
around I charge that straight away as
soon as I realize I charge it turn
around straight away I don't even bother
when we went to uh the manager's office
the other day yeah oh the Nando's thing
but I didn't even tell you
before I linked you yeah
my brain weren't working bro well I
might have a tumor siren okay my my
sense of direction yeah
fam I parked my car literally one road
away yeah
because I got there early I got there
like 45 minutes before you okay
park my car I was starving okay ran into
like prep or something to grab some bits
couldn't find my car again I'm walking
down streets bro oh my God couldn't find
my car again oh my God so luckily I
pulled up the Google Maps yeah yeah took
me back to my car I was like raw yeah
then obviously the Nando's thing
happened
um and then after I after I left you man
in Nando's same again bro I couldn't
find a car couldn't find my car again
what's going on bro damn my sense of
direction was crazy damn bro and this
man just saw me walking back and forth
back and forth and uh there was a point
where I spanned completely 360 around
nice I was on the spot just all the way
around bro I was getting lost I could
have witnessed it but I was lost in
London
lost in London I was lost bro I could
have witnessed that bro that's Peak that
is so Peak
uh what shouldn't be embarrassing but is
paying in coins instead of cash facts
hundred percent money's money at the end
of the day facts paid in coins instead
of cash flow nothing worse pressing no
tip on my pickup order
we had to charge that in La the no tip
thing we had to charge that they're like
these men wanted a tip for everything oh
bro duh the chicken [__]
um was it Walmart no target the chicken
Target I tried to fake fake us for for
some tips yeah how big the accent just
to to like entertain yourself to do the
accent as well yeah she was selling it
well there was somewhere else we went
there they asked for a tip I couldn't
believe it it was it wasn't in Coachella
when they tried um the food stands was
it not there Coachella food stands yeah
the [__] food stamps yeah yeah the
taco place yeah that was it was
screaming tip yeah do you remember I
walked off I didn't know what he was
saying I was speaking Spanish bro tip I
don't know what he was saying I walked
off because he couldn't have been saying
tip yeah yeah because you already you
know I'd already paid for it yeah and
then um yeah this weird over there
because you pay and then they ask you
after if you want to leave a tip oh my
gays La as well scopa we went to that
joint and the my man the way he he he
said the phrase pissed me off so
obviously American culture you have to
well you don't have to tip but um
Regular tip is 20 of the bill so I gave
him my card to wanting to pay for the
bill and he said unfortunately
um because it came it went through then
got transferred back yeah so basically
he said yeah it's not letting you do
multiple transactions yeah it has to be
all in one and I'm thinking oh when he
said multiple transactions I think
what's going on it's a it's a single
payment then he said oh I it won't let
me add my own tip so what I have to sign
for it I'll use a different card I can't
remember what you said he said basically
he's saying
the price of the meal is this yeah and
my tip is this yeah it won't let me do
two transactions yeah so you either need
to let me
um you need to either give me permission
to put the tip and the build together
yes in one transaction or give me your
second card that was it that wasn't
thinking there's no third option there's
no third option so what you're selling
me is I can pay the full bill as a
normal human being or you could try and
add a tip for yourself and I'll pay that
instead that's what you were saying he
wasn't even saying that bro he was
saying you're tipping me no matter what
I'm saying no matter what but he wasn't
giving me the option to just pay the
bill yeah yeah just to pay the bill and
he said multiple transactions thinking
there are no multiple Trends and you're
not choosing my tip by the way
I've decided my tip is this that thing
it baffles me bro they take it back to
the till and oh yeah oh yes bro in the
airport in the airport when I ordered
food they include the tip on the bill
okay and then there's an option for an
additional tip on top of that yes I
promise you there was is this where
you're watching the game we were
watching the game bro wow I sat at the
bar she didn't even have to walk over to
a table I sat at the bar she takes the
order puts it in she doesn't even like
do anything she doesn't even write
anything down you sit at the bar she's
got a tablet behind the bar ask you what
you want she pushes one button to say
Burger and Fries yeah and then nothing
else happens and then she gives me the
Ting and it's like oh the the 20 tip is
already included and then you look at
the receipt and it's like option for how
much extra tips you want to pay I was
like what is going on in this country
yeah bro it's so
it's so inherently built in that people
just throw the cash for tips like the
guy that was sat next to us talking to
the other guy about basketball about um
London and stuff or whatever he ordered
a drink and he just immediate reaction
slider tell him in the glass as well
it's like
antenna the trick was like five pounds
yeah bro was he all he did was bring you
a mixer that's all he did bring you
tipped him a tenner it's it's hard to
have that conversation without sounding
cheap but of course
this whole conversation is given if
you're a bro just say so yeah but but
it's not that it's not that it's the
prince
if you man did it right your tax rate
would already be on every single thing
we want to pay for how come how am I
paying for Jay's in a store and you're
telling me a figure like let's say
you're telling me 250 and I go to the
till you're telling me it's three bills
yeah you just told me yeah
so why is that still telling me free
boxing and the tip thing in America
needs to get you may need to sort it out
come together yes and change your system
yeah give me the price on the tag yeah
in fact buy it and do something yeah
yeah do something Biden because you are
killing the man it was so jarring anyway
back to it what shouldn't be
embarrassing but is trying out a new
exercise in the gym wow crying out and
Yeah exercise in the gym wow all period
going to a new gym completely when you
don't go to the layout you don't know
the layout you're just wondering like a
headless chicken bro it's jarring I've
been to gyms in my life but I hate the
anxiety of that yeah yeah where's the
leg stuff [__] scroll oh it's crazy it's
crazy being the new person at a job
a lot of stuff it's the worst thing I
can imagine I hate that feeling for
everybody every first day at any job
I've ever had I've left there with a
migraine that I can't describe because
you're just on edge
all the amount of times I have to say
mine my name especially the amount of
times people have gotten my name wrong
in my 32 years of living yeah yeah yeah
I couldn't thank God for this party you
know what I mean because now they know
now they know if you're getting along
with your business business and I'm not
talking to you if you get everyone
because I've done said my name on here
so yeah but the amount of times bro oh
it's so bro I'm so sorry yeah because I
already can't deal with that the first
day of working what's your name and
where did you work before here
what did you do before this
ask me again I dare you bro you have to
learn and you have you have to have the
task of learning hundreds of names
hundreds of names well I promise you no
it's not happening and you need to find
a buddy that day
otherwise you're eating drinking
Sleeping Alone by yourself I need to
click on to someone bro I need to click
on someone yeah I need to find someone
that has to do my choice facts because
they always are my last job they gave
you they give you buddies they give you
buddies and then they invite me to some
like
induction lunch no no where it's just
like me one of the team leaders yeah and
like three other people that are just
like Social Butterflies in the office
yeah and I have to sit there and eat
lunch with them
bro I sat there for two minutes I left I
said I'm not doing this [__] yeah
this is fake [__] I hate stuff like
that all of you I hate this double red
I know you're trying to be nice yeah
yeah [__] you bro what's the worst
feeling man
[Music]